[Music]
alright procrastination let's talk about
it a big topic and by the way we all
face it it is a ever-present evergreen
issue for a reason and even the people
you see a magazine covers most of them
there are a few mutants but they all
have things they put off and there are a
few different tactics approaches that I
found very helpful that I borrowed from
whether its guests on the compare show
or people I interviewed for tools Titans
- book here we go so down the left one
is break it down into the smallest
action conceivable right and there there
are a few different types here so if you
have a macro goal which is double the
number of podcast downloads per episode
alright I'm just giving that as an
example well we need to modify that to
make it really actionable the first is
making it hyper hyper specific alright
so we need a timeline at the very least
let's say within six months doubling and
this is a real example for me doubling
the number of podcast downloads
well downloads are ongoing so by what
point in time all right I want to double
the number of podcast downloads per
episode by week six after publication
and I want to accomplish that within six
months alright and then we could borrow
from David Allen and just ask what are
some of the what are some of the
prerequisites the component pieces of
doing that let's let's break it out into
say content and organic you can have
paid acquisition you make a long list of
these potential buckets of activities
from there you would look at next
physical actions and then this is
directly from getting things done and
you can apply that to any number of
these let's just say it's ten buckets
but you would ask yourself this is a
question I asked myself very often when
I'm procrastinating because there is
indecision and this is a particularly
dove procrastination in other words if I
have 10 things on my to-do list or 10
potential projects I could pursue what
to do in that situation and what I ask
myself is which one of these
done will make the rest irrelevant or
easier this is a key question I ask all
the time which one of these will make
all the rest easier to do if done first
or all the rest them irrelevant don't
even need to do them that is how I will
then hone in on one piece of the puzzle
and this can be applied all over the
place but let's just say it's the
doubled podcast it could be losing
weight alright you can see that's very
very amorphous we need timelines we need
an amount to lose and then you wanna
make it as small as possible so give you
a different example if you look if you
want to start flossing your teeth
who likes flossing the keys pretty much
nobody so how these start flossing your
teeth well you want to make it as easy
as possible to develop it as part of
your routine to make it as automatic as
anything else that you do consistently
and you could borrow from say BJ Fogg
who's done a lot of research at Stanford
and elsewhere make it as small as
possible meaning in the beginning do
less than you are capable of doing so
this is another key when you think
something is too big or onerous so it's
too intimidating or it's too much of a
pain in the ass alright so for flossing
you might say I'm only going to floss my
front two teeth that's three gaps that's
all you're going to do and you want to
make it again as easy as possible so you
might use a Waterpik or you might use
those disposable flossing gadgets so you
don't have to do you know tourniquets on
your fingers which is also one of the
side effects of flossing that deters
people make it as easy as possible now
this applies to a lot more than flossing
so I've talked to many of the people or
say tools of times people who are eight
time New York Times bestselling authors
or prolific musicians prolific music
producers like Rick Rubin is legendary
and it all comes down to tiny homework
assignments so Rick if he has a stuck
artist for instance he will say can you
get me one word or one line that you
might like for this song that you're
working on Mike tomorrow is that
possible many many homework assignments
alright so with a creative project in
the beginning that's one it's related to
a piece of advice that I got from Neil
Strauss eight-time York Times
bestselling author he
for the New York Times is written for
the rollin for Rolling Stone magazine
and that is lower your standards so he
doesn't believe in writer's block he
says your standards are just too high
you're creating performance anxiety for
yourself so the advice that I got from
another writer which matches with that
is to crappie pages per day so a lot of
people are like I'm going to kill it I
need an ambitious goal let me do 1,500
words 2,000 words per day for this book
I'm working on well there's a very high
probability that you're going to fall
short of that and then you will get
demoralized then you will get
intimidated by the task and then you
will start procrastinating so make the
hurdle make the success threshold really
really low that's what I've done for my
last three books is two crappy pages per
day that's all I need if I don't end up
using them that's fine I just need to
get out to crappy pages what ends up
happening with the flossing with the
writing with say exercise if you're
going to exercise you're making a new
year's resolution you'll make it an hour
a day four times a week done oh no no no
10 and you if you don't have an exercise
habit 5 to 10 minutes at the gym three
times a week plenty and in all those
cases you will feel successful because
you've checked your box for success and
then very often you will exceed that for
extra credit right and then already
added um I'll going for an extra 10
minutes well I'm already flossing my
teeth we'll do an extra four well I've
already hit my two pages but I'm feeling
great and I'm in the flow maybe I'll do
10 maybe I'll do 20 but it prevents you
from feeling like a failure this is very
very important that is what derails a
lot of people and it also makes the task
less intimidating so those are a few
recommendations from running
procrastination
some of them are time related so if you
are looking at a task and we've already
talked about chunking it down if it
looks gigantic and onerous and you
calculate in your mind well that's
probably going to take me a hundred
hours or three weeks however you look at
it you don't take the first step because
it's it's like taking a bite out of a
whale or something like that so you
could use technique for instance like
the Pomodoro Technique and people have
interpreted this in different ways but
it effectively means Sprint's of say 20
to 25
some people do 23 minutes where you are
like alright I know I can get this done
but I'm going to sprint for 20 minutes
25 minutes and then take a five-minute
break and then I won't sprint again for
20 to 25 minutes and the magic of those
time constraints I've talked about this
a lot is Parkinson's Law but the
complexity of a task swelling to fill
the time that it's allotted once you
have these positive constraints which by
the way for creative persons very
important to have positive constraints
being able to do anything you want all
the time is a recipe for disaster and
paralysis and procrastination and I'll
talk about one more constraint so you
can apply so you have something like the
Pomodoro Technique if it's email related
you can actually use a tool called email
game I won't go into long description
but email gime is the URL you can check
that out it avoids the inbox view and
forces you to answer sequentially so
I'll let people check that out that will
probably cut down your email clear
anytime by 40% or so the next way that
you can apply positive constraint is by
building in incentives and consequences
all this means is make yourself socially
accountable and you could use a site
like stick STI ckk comm you could use
coach dummy having someone else to hold
your feet to the fire and keep you
accountable or whatever goal you set for
yourself that could be a check in their
phone it could be a bet so financial
component which is very effective I've
seen high-ranking folks at Google lose
100-plus pounds because they had a bet
with a friend this is what got them
started their gym buddies if someone
didn't show up they'd to pay the other
person a dollar so it's incredible what
a small amount of money can do it you
could also put the other betting pool
say five people each put in 100 bucks
and the person to lose the most body fat
or improve their body fat percentage
using say a DEXA scan by the end of the
first quarter gets the 500 that is
hugely hugely effective and I think in
part not because the money you will win
but the money you will lose people work
a lot harder to counteract loss aversion
it turns out
so those are a few things that you could
utilize and I'll give you one kind of
wacky one that is from Mike Birbiglia
who's one of the most successful
comedians on the planet has done tons of
TV tons of movies and is fantastic at
stand-up there's a lot with this
American life and when he was
procrastinating working on his
screenplay his latest screenplay
he noticed that when he was accountable
to someone else he had a meeting he was
never late he was always early but when
he when he had a commitment to himself
to write he might put it off for hours
so he took a post-it he put it next to
his bed and this sounds ludicrous but it
said Mike and I think it was three
exclamation points you have a meeting
with yourself at 7 a.m. at cafe whatever
it was where he intended to work and
that actually for whatever weird quirk
of human psychology got him to stay on
track for his meeting with himself to
write a screenplay so that's another
Jedi mind trick that you might try on
yourself there are many tools in the
toolkit but keep it small keep it
defined rig it so you can win and when
in doubt figure out a way to create a
loss or shame if you don't actually
tackle your task and achieve some type
of measurable goal by a specific point
in time
[Music]